I've got a great documentary
recommendation for you today the
documentary is called accidental
courtesy if it sounds familiar it's
because the main subject of the film is
musician darrell davis who I've
interviewed twice on the program he is
known for not only being a great
musician and playing with legends like
Jerry Lee Lewis Little Richard Chuck
Berry he also has this practice hobby at
raviga Collett of meeting and meeting
with indie friending members of
extremist groups particularly the KKK
and many of these individuals have never
had a black guy as a friend and in
getting to know Darryl and re-examining
their beliefs some of them have opted to
leave the KKK and other white
supremacist groups featured in the
documentary which is available in both
Netflix and Amazon and you can find out
more david pakman.com slash
recommendations in the documentary
they're actually three two former david
pakman show guests featured darrell
davis who's the subject and star of the
film has been on the program twice mark
Potok from the Southern Poverty Law
Center is featured in the film he's been
a guest numerous times and there's a
great moment I'm not giving anything
away by telling you this is a great
moment where Darrell goes down to
Alabama and meets with mark Potok and
they basically have not a debate but a
conversation about the SPL sees
strategies for combating these groups
and Darryl strategies and you can see
that mark potok is just like
flabbergasted by the drastically
different method that darrell davis
employs and it's a really interesting
conversation that they have right
because Darryl Davis never really tries
to convince anyone he writes kind of
treats them as a fellow human being and
sees if they can relate on some other
aspect and a lot of times these people
who hold these racist views realize if I
can befriend someone like they're oh why
can't i befriend any other black person
right and of course the SPLC has a very
different approach which is trying to
systematically actually shut down these
groups and both both approaches I think
are legitimate in different ways also
appearing in the film is former KKK
member scott shepard also a friend of
the show and a friend of Darrell's who
has been a guest on the program at least
two and maybe three times so really
great film
accidental courtesy it is on netflix
where I watched it it's also available
on Amazon and you can find this film
along with all of the other films and
books and documentaries that I
recommended at david pakman.com slash
recommendations we've got a great show
for you today we will be taking phone
calls we will be answering audience
questions and of course if you have any
comments questions concerns about
anything that you hear on the program
today please follow me and tweet me on
twitter at d pakman the show also on
twitter at david pakman show we'll take
a break and be back with more right
after this